as of the latest data available on the
web there are 100 million users of chat
GPD not just 100 million it's 100
million and on growing so hey everyone
welcome to chat GPD tutorial for
beginners by simply learn in this video
we will discuss what is chat GPD gpt4
and working of chat gbt moving ahead
with this video we will see use of chat
GPT in various domains like SEO
marketing and web development everything
explained with Hands-On demo however we
will share the best tips and tricks for
chat GPT by the end of this video but
before we begin consider subscribing to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
on that note we present you Ai and
machine learning bootcamp elevate your
professional journey by enrolling in
this Ai and ml bootcamp amcos acquire
expertise in machine learning deep
learning and reinforcement learning
natural language processing generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and
Beyond this eiml bootcamp offers live
sessions led by industry professionals
practical Labs projects aligned with
industry needs and master classes by
Caltech instructors hurry up and enroll
Now find the complete course details
from the link in the description box so
without any further Ado let's begin with
chat GPD tutorial for beginners over to
our tutors meet John a talented
programmer who is looking to start a
company that used his personally
developed mobile application to connect
restaurants and customers for booking
and reservations
even though the app was ready John had
difficulty getting together a team for
his startup needing separate people for
sales marketing programming content
creation and customer support
hiring reliable Manpower while being
strict with his budget was getting
difficult
he reached out to his friend Ryan who
said John could start his company
without hiring any new people thanks to
just a single AI based tool John
couldn't believe it which led Ryan to
introduce chat gbt the Revolutionary AI
chatbot being developed by openai
it is a state-of-the-art natural
language processing or NLP model that
uses a neural network architecture to
provide responses
this means that the chat GPT bot can
answer questions without being
explicitly told what the answer is using
its own intellect unlike previous AI
chatbots
so how does chat GPT help John in
filling out his team
regarding sales chat GPT can provide
full-fledged sales pitches based on the
correct prompts it can provide tips on
how to pitch your product to businesses
removing the need for sales training
completely customized to your
requirements and your prompts if you
don't like some things about the
response you can ask for certain changes
and the chat bot will make sure they are
done when it comes to marketing chat EPT
can provide efficient marketing
strategies which can help new
entrepreneurs learn how to Market their
products to prospective clients it can
provide trending keywords that marketers
can use for SEO purposes while providing
ad copies for your website and blog
speaking of websites since John can do a
lot of the heavy lifting in the program
chat GPT can help proofread the code and
help out when looking for bugs to fix
apart from basic bug fixing it can also
provide sample code structures for
different programming languages allowing
Jon to focus more on improving core
functionality and workflow rather than
fixing basic code errors
websites and blogs content is very
helpful in gathering potential customer
leads
the Revolutionary bot can provide
full-length blog posts with near perfect
fast accuracy in seconds allowing
further customization like choosing the
length of the subject matter to the
complexity of language
for John's customer support the bot can
draft complete customer service emails
based on the situation saving time and
resources
the tone of the message can be changed
to reflect the nature of the message
creating an efficient alternative for
call center professionals
John was left speechless seeing this
level of Versatility from chat GPT and
wanted to implement it right away
however Ryan made sure John knew about
some drawbacks of the chatbot before
getting started
since the bot is trained mostly on data
up to 2021 many of the newer events May
still need to be discovered by chat GPT
even basic stuff like asking about the
current date and time is beyond its
scope much like the limited
understanding of context despite
providing near lifelike solutions to
certain problems even the accuracy of
many responses can be questioned since
the AI model is still learning and being
developed there is a section of the
public that believes the Revolutionary
tool can one day replace Google search
but that day seems far-fetched so far
because of the variety of issues people
keep running into and using chat GPT
however chat GPT poses a lot of promise
for the future of AI from full-skilled
automated divisions and organizations to
serving as the perfect digital assistant
open AI is creating a bot for the future
aimed at solving the problems of today
with the tools of tomorrow
the ability to carry out a myriad of
tasks with minimum Manpower will boost
productivity at organizations in every
sector thanks to the Revolutionary chat
GPT
so how do you think chat GPT will
benefit your daily life are you looking
forward to using the bot regularly for
work or personal life let us know your
thoughts in the comments below
meet John a software developer John
develops a program and now he realizes
the program is surrounded by a lot of
bugs
John starts exploring a solution
he surfs through the internet checks
programmer communities doubting every
step of the way John fills his problem
is not solved
desperate to find the solution John
meets his friend Adam
comes up with an idea of an artificially
intelligent and practical solution
called the chat GPT
Adam says chat GPT has the caliber to
systematically resolve all the bugs with
an elaborate explanation for every step
it makes
chat GPT is an AI trained model that
works in a conversational way
developed by open AI
fascinated by hearing this John asks
Adam to explain him in detail after Adam
explains that GPT AKA generative
retraining Transformer has come a long
way
before the introduction of GPT natural
language processing used to deal with a
specific task with large amounts of data
GPT was first released in 2018 which
contained 117 million parameters
gbt gpt2 and gpt3 each one is stronger
than the one before it
the main reason why GPT received little
attention was that it was more of an
idea or task than a finished product
but after the introduction of gpt2 it
gained a lot of attention as it could
accurately predict a word that would
begin a text
then they introduced gpt3 which is a
strong language model achieving
translation question answering and
Performing three-digit arithmetic
but chat GPT Stands Tall compared to all
other achievements of openai so how does
it work chat GPT uses deep learning
techniques to generate human-like text
it is based on the machine learning
model derived from the class called the
large language model
chat GPT is a byproduct of instruct GPT
instruct GPT introduced a strategy for
integrating human feedback into the
training process to match model outputs
this Innovative technology made chat GPT
exceptional
it is trained on the massive data sets
of text from the internet and learns
from the patterns and relationships
between words and phrases it responds to
a prompt by determining the next word
based on the context then repeats the
process until a stop condition is met
as a result chat GPT can produce various
logical responses to various queries and
prompts the most important components of
chat GPT are the Transformer model and
language model
coming to the Transformer model it is a
neural network architecture designed to
process sequential data it consists of
multiple layers of self-attention and a
feed forward Network
after the Transformer model has
processed the input a decoder generates
the output
the decoder uses the contacts provided
by the encoder to generate the response
the model is trained using unsupervised
learning and fine-tune unspecific tasks
using supervised learning for successful
completion of tasks it needs retrained
data
the model first encodes the input text
then converts it to a numerical
representation which can be processed by
the model's neural network
this encoding is done using the embedded
layer that Maps the work
then comes the language model
chat GPT is trained as a language model
trained to predict the next word in a
sequence given the previous words
the language model intends to produce
rational consistent and meaningful
output
the pre-trained chat GPT can be tuned
for a specific task
so chat gtt passes a fine tuning test by
answering questions generating text
summaries or generating text in response
to a query
overall chat GPT is a powerful language
model with a combination of techniques
like deep learning machine learning
neural networks and natural language
processing
can chat GPT change a wide variety of
business tasks John asked
chat GPT possesses the ability to
automate content creation on social
media create chatbot and e-commerce
sites provide medical assistance by
acting as a symptom checker write code
and assist a developer
thus chat GPT can change the working of
every industry now John can resolve any
coding issue without looking into any
other resources
but like any other technology chatgpt
comes with a few limitations that can be
its Achilles heel
chat GPT is capable of developing
content up to 2021 it finds difficulty
in providing logical reasoning in
certain situations
and also chat EPT lags in Translation
summarization and sometimes question
answering but above all chat GPT has
shown remarkable ability by providing
accurate answers flawlessly in a
creative way in very short periods of
time
whether you attack Enthusiast a expert
or just curious about the new and
exciting development you won't want to
miss this discussion about the latest AI
sensation I'm talking about chat gbt a
highly Advanced language model based on
gpt3 technology developed by open AI
chat GPT is a state of art language
generation AI model that has captured
the attention of millions of people
around the world it has been trained on
a massive data set of text Data making
it one of the most largest language
models to date but do you know a new
version of GPD is coming up it's called
gpd4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gpt3 now you might
be wondering what are these parameters
so what it means when a user sends a
query to the New Year version of star
GPT then it will process that query with
all one trillion parameters to deliver a
correct and suitable response isn't it
mind-blowing not only that gpt4 will
have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation Tech
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
Fable studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability
gpt4 has the possibility of being
utilized for additional functions such
as generating images and videos this is
due to the fact gpt4 is constructed
using the Transformer architecture which
has demonstrated Effectiveness in
multiple machine learning assignments
including computer vision psychologist
and cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that GPT 4 will
blow the mines He also mentioned that
gpt4 will totally Eclipse chair gbt as
it has more parameters and is being
trained with more data however the CEO
Sam Altman debunks false information
surrounding the company's upcoming chat
gpt4 Altman said that he did not have an
actual AGI that is an artificial general
intelligence that could travel humans in
learning and existence
the release of chat GPT and other AI
powered chatbots had has a major impact
on Google search business with the New
York Times reporting that it prompted
Google's management to declare State
emergency referred to as code red gpt4
with its improved complexity and quicker
response time has the potential to
enhance communication by making it more
natural and accurate for instance short
sentence responses from a chat board can
reduce the likelihood of people clicking
on ads this AI technology could bring
about a major transformation in the
economy Google employees have been
assigned the task of developing AI
products with gpt4 that can match the
capability of gpt3 such as its
capability of generating art music and
other visuals that openai is currently
capable of Microsoft has invested 3
billion dollars into the open Ai and is
reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as deported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gpd4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 2012
3 Matt McLovin a venture capitalist with
knowledge of GPT 4 hinted that the new
system May possess is multimodal
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and songs the
gpt4 chatbot built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to chatgpt
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam Altman has cautioned not to set
expectations to height so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what gpt4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about chat gbt4 do let us know in the
comment section below now this shows
that AI is one of the most sought out
technology in today's day and age during
our childhood we have heard the
fictional stories of robots taking over
various household courses making the
lives of humans easy peasy but if you
are not aware then these fictional
stories are turning into reality though
not in the form of physical robots but
yes in the form of computer programs and
apps with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way chat
GPT is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a
as we discussed earlier Chad GPT is the
application of artificial intelligence
and machine learning so before we move
ahead consider subscribing to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply land we
know that SEO rankings depends on
various factors like on-page
optimization of page optimization and
more while using chat gbt we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
SEO ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chat gbd
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we will find some
good keywords
foreign
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just me good keywords to create a
blog
gone with Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are few places like
Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
foreign
keywords related to top 10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for search for for search
rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to uh
optimize the blog with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh chat jpg provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to several number of words like
if this Blog has two thousand or five
thousand words you can just ask chat GPT
reduce it to two thousand or thousand
words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords to increase its reach
suggest
you
more development
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
title helps the user to click on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimized our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
add the best
suitable
title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
foreign
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and
okay so it is showing the relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blob using
all these factors
visit in Japan
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
and the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me if you would
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these uh blog pages in
your website or if you have created any
of these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our block
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 pieces to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this block
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and uh see if
we are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image ideal for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
the mount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
good
title and
Alt
tag
for
packaging image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
Fuji
Five Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
choose
the mound
you'll see image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
Mount Fuji
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us a suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of UNS and unsplash
pixels or Shutterstock to download the
image so we can really navigate to these
websites and download some of the
required image
for our blog
so we we have uh completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
for your blog page
suggest me
suggest
do ideas
for
above
block
okay so if we are getting few of the
video ideas
which of the
above idea is best match for my blog so
try to extract anyone from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide radio
optimization optimization
ideas
optimizations
for
amount
using video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
suggest me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags for
the
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black
a repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is uh which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
yes
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
stop them
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate this kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO
optimized
URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four shading
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a battling for from
your blog you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above
block so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that social engines are really in
love with the unique content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to chargeability
is not able to identify the duplicate
content however it is suggesting us some
of the tools like copyscape or siteliner
to understand if the content we are
creating for our blog is duplicate or
not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create a unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really not are not likely to get
searched because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the sharp GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of
upper website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things on that note we
present you Ai and machine learning
bootcamp elevate your professional
journey by enrolling in this Ai and ml
bootcamp course acquire expertise in
machine learning deep learning and
reinforcement learning natural language
processing generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and Beyond this
eiml bootcamp offers live sessions led
by industry professionals practical Labs
projects aligned with industry needs and
master classes by Caltech instructors
hurry up and enroll Now find the
complete course details from the link in
the description box Jack GPD is truly a
fascinating technology change in how we
interact with language it's the result
of years of research and development by
open AI who have trained the model on a
massive amount of Text data to create a
machine that can easily understand and
generate human-like text imagine you are
a digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that chargeivity uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chat GPT will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how change apt can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every field be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CIA jpt and your options
are option A Elon Musk and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and satyana data
option C Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
option D segma and masayoshi Sun Drop
your answer in the comment section below
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of charge GPT in digital
marketing its main USB is smart human
sounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first owner agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learn digital marketing Master scores
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
and vola it gave us a no version of that
same content now let's try to convert it
into email newsletters we digital
marketers often send emails to promote
our products and services so let's give
it a query as can you convert it to
email newsletters
thank you
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter a new query what is
Facebook
[Music]
it has given us a journal overview of
Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase it
more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well chatgpt can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing course
site
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
give us some keywords you can ask it to
reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
[Music]
here we have our article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to se optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
[Music]
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
here we have fully SEO optimized article
with meta title and meta description
where the SEO optimized URL chat GPT can
also be used to train your customer
service chat boards but we can discuss
the process in some other video chatgpt
is well burst with its content writing
capabilities it can even help you write
product marketing campaigns let's try it
with this query the query is write a
product marketing campaign Force
Implement digital marketing courses
thank you
well chatgpt has done it again this
campaign looks interesting and it will
be able to generate more leads for
simple lens courses chatgpt can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query as write a script
for five net YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
foreign
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
since my last query was related to
Simply none chat Deputy assured that I
work for simplion and I wrote a customer
collaboration email that looks
professional plus easy to read and
understand let me tell you what charge
gbt is chargpt is a machine model that
generates human-like text responses it's
been generated on a massive data set of
text and can generate highly accurate
responses to a wide range of queries
but how can charge DBT be used for web
development
there are number of ways for example
child Jeopardy can generate website
content improving SEO and boosting
engagement
chat GPT can also be used to create chat
boards that can interact with customers
in a natural and engaging way now let's
look at some of the real live examples
of how charged GPT has been used for web
development so for example if I ask rgbd
to create a e-commerce website for me it
will easily create it so let's see it
please create a website
for me
in HTML
and CSS
so there is one point that I wanted to
tell you guys if you want to ask chargpt
for anything just give good description
about it so it can give you a good
response if I tell you tell it more
about my requirements it will generate
good quality of product okay
so let me delete please create a website
for me in CSS and HTML
that should
some
like orange
and blue
right
and
where I'm selling
okay now lay wait for the response of
charge gbt it will create us
the things the code okay now it's
writing the HTML code right
so I'll tell you more about it like for
example e-commerce sites use chart GPT
to generate product descriptions
improving their SEO and driving sales
customer service team use LGBT to create
automated chat boards that can help
customers with common queries and there
are so many other things also like uh
content creators also use charge GPT to
generate engaging content for their
website right so let's wait a couple of
minutes more until it gets completed
right so as you can see it's giving us a
proper response of everything
as it created this file for us
and we can just easily copy it from here
and I have logged into my online editor
you can open any editor if you want
so this is the online editor that I'm
working on right now I'll clean this
so as you can see
e-commerce website is ready right
so this is a very basic website but
chargpt has created this for us
it's a very easy website like very basic
but as the instructions that I gave it
it applied all the things that it's
using yellow color but I asked for
orange but it's fine as for blue color
so this is also fine but before asking
charg you should know a little bit about
coding right so in H1 tag
here
you have to write the heading is the
header tag inside that it's the H1 The
Heading one
okay so here I'll write my website name
Android website
and then you can see the joint
website right
so how can you use stat GPT for your own
development projects first you have to
familiar yourself with the programming
languages in tools that are compatible
with charge EBT and it will only knows
the data until 2021
so once you have done that you can
experience with charge gbt to see how it
can benefit your project
right if I ask him to create wait I'll
show you guys some of the things that
rgbt can do
create a header
so I have told rgbt to create a header
and make it functional and also add
page product page and contact this page
make it a little more I have written
make it attractive right so let's see
it will write us a code for that so
until then let me tell you the use cases
so as I already mentioned chat GPT has
already proven its values in various web
development scenarios
for example e-commerce platform use
charjabi to generate product
descriptions boosting their search
engine optimization and driving more
sales
customer service team employee charge
GPT to build interactive chat boards
that provides instant and accurate
responses to customer queries enhancing
the overall user experience
so optimize the generated content from
SEO ensures that the text generated by
charge gbt aligns with relevant keywords
and follow SEO best practices right so
with the help of charge GPT SEO things
this can help improve your website
visibility in search engine results and
it can create natural and authentic
chatbot experience so when using charge
GPT to develop chat boards focus on
creating conversation that feels like
human
use context and personalization to
ensure user engagement and build trust
leverage our GPT for customer engagement
Beyond generating content right charge
apt can help engage user on your website
also for instance you can use it to
develop interactivity and so many other
things okay so now let's see
what child GPT has created for us right
let's copy this
and paste it on the online editor that I
have showed you
I don't recommend using online editor
you can have a visual studio code it's
very good
so it doesn't have any CSS I guess yeah
add your customer custom styles for
product pages here yeah so as I know we
have to write the CSS here but it's fine
I have to show you something different
so as I told it to create the e-commerce
website so it give a given its name as
welcome to e-commerce website but we can
change it from here the title of the
website we can change it right
and I have told it to create home
product and contact page right as I have
showed you so it has created the same
thing that I have told charging video to
create for me as in the products page
there's no things added right now but we
can add it add your products and their
details here as it's written in the code
also I guess yeah in this section part
we can add our product and the things
that we want right now let's ask charg
to create
Circle
create five
server different
radius
or 20 pixels
to
red pixel right and
[Music]
and
close blue and
Orange
now let's see whether it can create five
circles of different radius for us or
not
right and now it's writing the HTML file
for us
let's wait a couple of seconds to see
whether it can create so it given us the
things we want but I don't think so it
has
different
radius okay as you can see in the CSS
part it is given everything a different
height and width let's copy the CSS
first or HTML anything you want and
we'll paste it on the online editor
let's go again and copy the HTML part
also and
pasted here now
we will
down and as you can see the first circle
is small and then the last one is the
largest one right so as you I have given
it the charge DBT the instructions that
I want this thing or that thing it has
created the same thing that I told him
to do right so it's all about
instructions but as I know that this is
width and height this is very simple
thing but when you go on python or
JavaScript or Java it'll be a very
complex things so I recommend first
learn the language and then use
chargeability to improve it right so
many developers in programmers use
charge gbd to enhance their productivity
you want to learn it so it's very good
for learning purpose also if I tell it
I want to learn
Javas I say
Java
from
where
should
start
start learning it
give me
some
princess
and
some
good
sides
from where
I can start
with the
Links of them
right so I asked charity to tell me from
where should I start learning the HD
Java so it's now telling that's great
Java is a popular programming language
as there are many resources available to
help you learn it here are some of the
website and resources where you can
start learning Java right
so it's giving me Oracle Java tutorials
it's very good to learn Java from Java
programming on core serum it's giving
some of the renowned Java certification
courses but I recommend you to take our
Java certification full stack Java
certification the link will be in the
description box for that it's a very
good certification for newly starting
developer or programmer or experience
one also so from there you will start
learning Java from scratch so that is
also very good
you can also check it out right so as I
told it to give me the instructions from
how to learn Java so it just gave me
everything with the links right
so now
let's get to
give me any
projects ideas
for
react
yes
right
so now it's telling me
you can create a project on react for
from starting from to-do list which is a
very basic app when you start learning
any language you started by from to-do
list only or doodoo app whatever you say
next one is weather app movie Library
which is also very good practice for
Library uh for react developers to start
learning reaction and the e-commerce
store it's a Founder chat application
and these are the 10 projects that they
the charge ability told us to learn
right so it's very good you can ask it
anything if you don't know anything
like I'll tell you
yeah JS right
I don't know think
about react yes
please
about it
so I told it I don't know anything about
the ideas I know about the IGS but it's
like I want to see what it's saying you
can also check out the projects that I
have created on react on this simply
learns YouTube channel so uh that's
saying everything certainly react.js is
a popular JavaScript library for
building user interfaces it was
developed by Facebook and it is widely
used for building single page
application
it's a dynamic application
so some of the key points of react
component based architecture virtual Dom
and declarative syntax unidirectional
data flow react Hooks and so many other
things so as you don't know in anything
about react it will tell you to get
started with react you can begin by
learning fundamentals of JavaScript and
familiarize yourself with HTML and CSS
once you have a good understanding of
these Technologies you can explore
react.js by following tutorials reading
documentation I recommend documentation
because it's very good you will get a
deep understanding of that then move to
tutorials and all and build small
projects it is also very good thing
start from learning from the project you
will learn more react official document
is here so Excel resource to learn react
yes from scratch additionally there are
various online courses tutorials and
YouTube channels dedicated to teaching
learning reactors such as reactors on
these platforms and you can and also
learn react from our YouTube channel
remember to to practice regularly build
projects to refine
yours learning and leverage the react.js
community for support and guidance on
that note we present you Ai and machine
learning bootcamp elevate your
professional journey by enrolling in
this Ai and ml bootcamp course acquire
expertise in machine learning deep
learning and reinforcement learning
natural language processing generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPT and
Beyond this eiml bootcamp offers live
sessions led by industry professionals
practical Labs projects aligned with
industry needs and master classes by
caltic instructors hurry up and enroll
Now find the complete course details
from the link in the description box I'm
sure you all are aware of charging at
this point the Revolutionary new AI
based chatbot developed by openai have
taken the World by storm thanks to its
near lifelike responses and a very
intricate pattern of answers they have
never seen this level of expertise from
a chatbot before which really made us
think to what extent can we push it
there are many questions on lead code
that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far charge GPD can
take us hobby finally reached the stage
where AI is going to replace us let's
find out so basically here we will be
listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if chat GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
get started so here is the lead code
let's see uh in our list which is the
first question that we are going to
implement in our chat GPD and see if
it's able to solve it or not
mainly will focus on hard category
questions only so
according to my research there's a
question of median
of two sorted arrays
so as you can see the success rate is
35.7 so let's see the charge Equity is
able to do this question so first let us
go through the question
okay
press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted arrays so right now it's
particularly giving logic which we can
actually imply to solve this question
and this is a good but the charge GPD is
that before uh giving the code it's
actually explaining how they are putting
the logic in together in the code
so probably you can use this logic to
create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code is
quite a learning program
is in Python so if you are looking for
your Solutions on chat GPT you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in
so okay it's it's also gives that okay
that the time complexity will be o log
Min m or n so let's see if it
the case or not
so we have copied it
and we quickly paste it over here
as you can see
uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh
syntax and you can see the indentation
over here is perfect but here it's not
so I feel that something like this is
something with lead code
so let me just quickly Rectify this you
can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct program
uh now you can see here we have an error
let's see copy this and see what chart
GPD has to say for this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums 1 and nums two ask GPT if it
can write the code with self-argument
and see if it's correct
believe that if it can pass a
self-argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new code
okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three arguments
let's
copy this code
put it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process
oh no this time it's fine okay so now
quickly run this program let's see if
this time it passes all the test cases
or not
I think it doesn't needs because the
class is already mentioned over here
uh
yeah
okay the runtime is 35 Ms and as we can
see case 1 and case 2 is definitely
passed
so
let us see if
this code can pass all the test cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there is a runtime error
so
as the first question in our list chat
GPT was unable to solve let's move on to
our next question
that is zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for it
this is the question here also you can
see the success rate is definitely below
50 and the difficulty level is medium so
the Hard One charging Beauty was not
able to solve let's see if this can be
done
question so it will give a string that
will be written in its exact pattern on
a given number of rows
and then you have to read the line in a
certain
as you can see over here
we have to write the code that will take
a string and make this conversion given
in a number of row
is also means a certain amount of
certificate uh repeat that's also given
a certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning everything
so let's quickly copy this
okay
now that we have mentioned the
specifications
uh let me quickly
feet
and pasted now let's see what code it
has to generate
it's implementing the code in C plus
plus so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's quickly
like the code or it's already C plus
plus okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and Java
and it's generating an alternative code
as well for us
that's Sharp
just quickly copy this code
um
the one I think it's uh okay so it's
generating in uh
Java
let's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C plus plus one the first code
generated by it
uh is correct or not
okay copy the code
he stood over here
dilation error
okay okay
28 okay
so let's do this later
the one thing
definitely this time we have mentioned
all the constraints criteria
specifications that we wanted in a code
but again
judging
questions we have implemented till now
let's see if it has any success rate in
further
okay it seems okay
now it is okay so this time it is uh
generating the solution or considering
the error in Java
see what it has to say in Java and we'll
make it specific that the error was in C
plus plus program so generates the
correct code
plus plus program
what it has to say
oh those things
let's see so this error is something
related to the compiler and now it is
giving the updated code in C plus plus
is the correct one or not
apologizing for making arrows in their
Solutions
quite fascinating
[Music]
um
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or not
let me see the all the braces are
covered over here or not
I think it's missing a brace
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was missing
um I don't
for that
definitely something with the code but
okay we can give that to charge GPT it
was partially lead quotes issue because
we were copying still it was not giving
the error that there is a brace missing
has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3M is now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not mind it this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraints
so let's see if this has to into
okay so this time it has passed all the
test cases but still my conclusion with
this question is uh it was still not
able to generate the solution in one go
uh but so I can give that to charge gbt
because the first error that we faced
was more of a lead coaches issue
because it was something with company
and charge gbt was able to give a proper
oh now let's go back to our problems
list
so
right now the score is one and one it
was unable to solve one question and one
not
so let's have a look at the third
question and see if that brings any
difference to the chart gpts
scoreboard right now or not
third question that we are going to deal
with is substring
with
concatenation of all words
this is in the category again and the
success success rate is 31.1 percent
which is even lesser than the first
question that we faced which was median
of the two sorted Aries
we're trying here we are actually trying
to cover all the Spectra the huge
Spectra of different types of
questions and you know categories
available in coding and to give you an
idea of how
beneficial charging can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you can say well
established companies among companies
so here this video is specifically for
you to give an idea that whether you can
use it for your benefit and you know to
get an idea or you can actually
compare it with
your
subjects uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third question
is that you're given a string and then
array of strings probably words and all
the strings or words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has a b c d e f then a b c
d e f basically uh has to know the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that
there's a big added
uh
e c d b e f is not a concatenated
substring because it is not the
concatenation of any permeation of words
so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S string
also you can choose any order for it
here it has also given a
two examples for you to
understand the question in a better
perspective
now
really uh copy this question and see if
what programming language algebra
chooses to answer this time
but with no chat again
will be these constraints
okay it's just a question
okay
this is the solution that we're getting
right now you requested a model that is
not compatible with this engine please
contact us through our help center at
help
dot openai.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to implement
uh your task in it so again let's
quickly
paste it over here
that we want a code write the code
return now
press enter
same definitely it's not giving the same
error
let's see it this time it charging PD
has anything to give as a solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python
moving every time chargeability doesn't
follows a similar pattern as you can see
in the first question it explained the
logic first and then implemented the
code second time it just gave you the
approach not the logic and then
implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for C plus
plus
and this time it's straight away wind
for the code so definitely we can say
that it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think charge
if it is capable to capable enough to
give that
that the code is generated let's quickly
copy it
and
paste it over here
I feel the indentation issue is going to
be there
but it was not there okay
F probably I think if we backspeed
issue let me quickly Rectify this and
I'll
show you once the indentations are
but
the indentation is projected now let's
have a look
at the Gold if it's correct or not let's
quickly run it
definitely it has a given our first
syntax error again
I can see that even a specific video
question it definitely goes to at least
one error which is mainly the syntax one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with the
charge GPT code generation
okay
all right we have given the error okay
it seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function typins
were introduced in the version we are
using is lower than that okay so
basically it's generating now in the
python version uh probably this code is
well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that helps
on it
is actually generating the code
okay again
given the other one I think it's again
something with the self
uh
one the new code generated is here
we'll definitely come back to that error
and have a look at the Python 3 code
also
uh first let's copy this code
and
in giving the same error
and see what it has to say
uh you know every time the charge APD
generates the python code we cannot
ever takes self as an argument but
believe that
as you can see when we start the code
it's already mentioned what arguments we
need to pass from
a particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code so
that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct and
the one goal so probably I'll get this
point to GPT it's something with the
lead code because it's passing that
parameter and everything we have to
mention that parameter pretty much when
we do the chargeability is able to solve
the question so let's see well let me
actually mention that
because self parameter self argument
from that parameters I'm gonna make it
one of the parameters
it's processing that
yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code and you know
item three
but we can give that to charge GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument
so once we mention that error and when
we mention that specification that if
charging between pass self argument
through that particular function in that
code the solution is pretty much
right so here it's also implementing and
giving the answer
okay it also has mentioned that it's
important to mention import imported
list and counter so
okay
just copy this because again there will
be a lot of uh impatient issues
okay now that we have it
copy the code
I was already mentioned so yeah we'll
just
copy it from the function
paste it
let's run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or not
yeah there's an indentation issue
let me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28 MS
now let us submit this question and see
if it is able to pass other test cases
or not
accepted
so it is able to pass all the test cases
and I think this is something with lead
code again uh whenever we are generating
the python code we are actually passing
self argument uh in lead code but charge
GPD is not assuming it so this solution
is definitely correct
even though we are specifying everything
we will have to be more specific that we
have to run one more argument uh from
the function so that it you know
generates the solution in one go so let
us try that in our next question
but we can definitely see charge APD was
able to solve this so now the scoreboard
is two one one uh among the three
questions it is definitely able to solve
two questions even the first question it
was able to generate a correct solution
but it was not that accurate to pass all
the test cases
to a question list
the next question that we are going to
cover is in Queens
category but still the success rate is
63 over here again a new genre or
question we are covering over here let
us see it
solve it or not definitely the success
rate shows that many people were able to
do it definitely more than half of
people who have attempted it so see if
the question can
this AI can beat that or not
so I have to copy this question this
question mentions that the end Queens
puzzle is the problem of placing n
Queens on an N into N Chess board such
that no two queens attack each other
given an integer n return all distinct
solutions to the end Queen puzzle
so basically n is any given number and
you have to create a puzzle of end in
and you have to arrange all the Queens
in such uh you know way also the number
of Queens in the board will be equal to
the number
in and in such a way that it is not able
to attack each other in any case
puppet this part of the question
and the constraint is
just one let me
that it will be easy to keep a track of
what all questions charity is able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in interviews uh whenever you actually
go to technical rounds and for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular
they are considered as very uh suitable
questions to check to check your you
know IQ and to check your potential that
how well aware you are towards your
coding potential
now we have pressed enter it is giving
the logic it is going to implement in
its code one approach to solve the end
Queens puzzle is to use backtracking
I guess to start by placing a queen in
the First Column of the first row so
let's see if the course
again capable to you know
solve it or not
again it's giving the python code
generating the code let us quickly see
whether it's python or Python 3
python 3.
okay
once the code is generated I'll also
write that you need to pass one more
argument from the main function
uh that is self and let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or not
should what I want and let this see sure
here's an example of how you can pass an
additional parameter self let's see if
it suits
the code or not
from the 12 and queen function is a
method of the end Queens class and it
takes self as its first parameter
followed by the integer n so yes this
solution does take self as a parameter
so let's see if this can
run in one go or not because this time
we've already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is
syntax error of not mentioning parameter
self
actually
let me see the indentation if it's
correct or not
this time uh let us quickly run this
class
okay there you go now you can see that
it has actually run the code in one go
and all the test cases are passed in one
go even the runtime is 39 Ms so
definitely charge gbt is able to provide
the solutions the Logics in a proper
manner it's just that we have to be more
specific with what we want exactly uh
from charity between right now we can
see that it has been able to
successfully generate 4 out of five uh
questions that we have actually
implemented till now out of which four
are from hard category
let us submit this code and see if it
also covers all the test cases
internally fit in for this question just
a second I think I will have to submit
it again
thank you cool it has accepted all the
test cases and this question is done by
child GPT it has actually implemented
this question that we are going to cover
till now I can say charge gbd has taken
the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge success
but um I can still give that to charge
upd as it is in Ai and still in a you
know developing mode but still if it can
give you 90 of the output correct it is
a pretty decent and you know amazing
thing to do
question is shortest sabare with some at
least K now let me search
for it
again this question is from hard
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see if this
question can be solved by charging
let's have a look at the question given
an integer add in nums and an integer K
return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with the sum of
at least K so if there is no such sub
array return minus 1.
so
the body is a contagious part of an
array it has also given a description of
what an array is or what sub array is
so now that we have
create a new chat
and let me
explains
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a code
so I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the code
specific
so yes it's giving an implementation of
the algorithm in Python uh again we can
see it's not the Python 3 it's python uh
little no version of python
um
could be
H2
python
then we have to pass self
so it has generated code and explain
what all variables and what will
statements have the individual
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adheres to it and
generates new code with self parameter
okay so here
is the new code with self animated
passed through the main function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
till now that it was able to generate
logical and you know
pretty much decent solutions for every
question
the spouse to the class as an argument
when an object is created and is stored
as an instance variable the shortest sub
array takes K as an argument which is
the target sum so basically it's trying
to explain the code that what exactly
it's doing and what individual
statements have as an influence on the
code
and whatever parameters they are passing
what influence or what position they
hold in the code
so definitely charge APD is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it
and wins generating the code as you can
see here we have legit explain the whole
code how it's actually functioning
that's a good way to you know put
emphasis on you know put a confidence on
the solution
remove this
I better okay let me
okay so it's apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or adhering to the syntax error or type
error generated like
correct or not
you mentioned that here direct weather
takes two arguments one for the nums
array and one for the K which was the
errored exactly
and it's again explaining the whole code
so that one person who watches code or
you know logic could understand the
functionality of it
let's say this code can run
food
checking for indentation removing class
and run
it's one more type error
let's copy it and
and we mentioned that we want
self-argument to be passed
it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice
so let's see if this time it can work
out
issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion seems that I
misunderstood
that you are trying to call the function
directly without creating an instance of
the class and that
function outside of the class and simply
Call It by passing the parameters like
this okay the code is definitely
generated by itself so definitely I am
not calling any function uh
the code I copied was actually generated
by charging itself so it's contradicting
its own pointers Maybe
right we have copied the question uh
sorry the code
let's paste it
again look for indentation
and run this code
okay once again it is not able to you
know
us
time error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste it
again according to chat GPD it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anyway
generated by Char GPT so yeah
this time I think GPT is trying to
contradict its own logics
let's see if the current code can do the
miracle of solving this question
last
and run
okay so after four attempts of running
the codes generated by charge GPT on
delete code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so
I can I have a very contradicting point
right now uh
not exactly contradicting more of a
skepticism that okay Chad Jeopardy does
generate a proper code or logic but it
doesn't considers all the criterias or
it also has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong context
so I feel that when we as a human try to
solve these questions we definitely try
to implement all the Logics and if we
get it we can actually get the code in
one go
magic or you know demand of the question
and be AI being the superior version or
you know trying to be the superior
version of human brain and going to the
extent of a human brain
still faces those issues
can be uh you know drawback for chat GPT
because you can see for this specific
question we have face multiple types of
error and we have seen charge a pretty
contradicting its own prior code
so
definitely this is something to consider
or you know something to think about
submit this code
and after like I said after giving four
attempts it is still not able to pass
all the test cases it is only able to
six pass 61 out of 97 test cases
which is almost 70 percent of the test
cases 30k percent of this test cases are
still not passed even though we
mentioned all the constraints we have
mentioned the comments we have mentioned
all the errors that but this particular
code can go through
still it was not able to generate the
proper code that could go through all
the test cases
so
this was a fail for chart GPT uh at
least till now we have made out this
point that charge GPT is definitely not
able to solve every question
array with same average
for it
array with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success rate is only
25 percent
Let me refresh it and remove this code
now let's have a look at the code what
it demands so you are given an integer
Harry nums now you should move each
element of nums into one of two arrays e
and B S and B are non-empty and the
average of array a is equal to average
of array B
now return true if it is possible to
achieve that
condition is not justified
so given a note that for an array uh
average array is the sum of all the
elements of array over the length of
array okay so it is giving the lodge of
how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly
and also it has given a few examples to
give you how the code needs to be
projected or implemented
please copy the code and paste it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array I am comparing the averages
of the subsets so definitely it has
given you the approach uh the way you
can actually think of solving this
question
however this approach would have a Time
complexity so it's also giving that this
approach can have a Time complexity of O
to the power n so again it's suggesting
a different approach a more efficient
approach that will be using dynamic
programming now that can be used to find
the subsets with a specific average and
create a 2d array with the length of I
and J which that will be the length of
the two
we have actually given as input and
represents whether or not it is possible
to get a sum of J using the first
moments of the nums array
so
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o and S so definite it is not
given a code let me ask for it
not for every question chart GP is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them
as you can see I've mentioned this time
to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
it's also mentioning comments that what
every snippet of the code is actually
for and what it will do like here you
can see it will fill the 2dr ADP uh DP
stands for dynamic programming this here
it has mentioned initialized the First
Column as true so it is also mentioning
the comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better way
it's also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums are
is non-empty and that the elements of
the nums array are non-negative integers
okay also the above implementation will
return the possible subset that can be
formed by the array to fulfill the given
condition and not Boolean true and false
but that's what we want exactly right
uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and
see this code can run or not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass self
uh
parameter
indentation
and
foreign
specifically
uh
sure here is an example of how you can
pass the self parameter so now the
current solution will pass self
okay
great there was an error okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the
criteria I just mentioned that I need
self parameter to be passed through the
function can partnership
so I have copied it and let's quickly
paste it over here
uh you know pass
all the cases are not wait uh we need to
remove this
okay it's done now quickly just run this
program
okay so here is uh
error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what Char
GPT has to say about this error
okay the error message solution object
has no attribute
uh split array same average suggests
that there is no method named with this
in the solution class so it is likely
that the test case is trying to call
this method but it does not exist in
your implementation anyway that I have
not mentioned this method this was given
by charity itself so again we can see
the condition that it is contradicting
its own so again it has generated new
response and it says that it should
resolve the issue and the test case
should be able to call this particular
method correctly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see that
now is it able to run or not and pass
all these test cases or not
and click on run
okay now the new generated response it
does works for this particular question
and the runtime is 12 Ms and it
trespasses the first two cases mentioned
so let us quickly submit this code and
see if the code is perfectly you know
fine to deal with all the test cases
actually fed by lead code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60 percent of uh total amount of
test cases
so let's move on to the next question
that is find substring with given hash
value so let me quickly search for this
question
find
substring
with
cash value again it's
it's a question from hard category and
the success rate is
22.2 percent so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given integers B and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters SPM
uh this is the logic given how we want
our output to be demonstrated in certain
value or how the hash can be generated
the particular formula uh how you can
get the hash value of your you know
string
so the question is you are given a
string and then teachers
and you have to return the first
substring of that string of length uh
given to you here it's K the test cases
will be generated such that an answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
chart gypri consoles so that it gets
all the specifications
open the code and
so I have copied the code and I'll paste
it over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my class
and
my dad faces a type error so let's move
on to the next question again we saw
that Chachi but he was not able to solve
this particular question coming back to
our list the next question in the list
that we are going to cover is partition
array into two arrays to minimize some
difference let's quickly search for that
question
I want to shouldn't add a
to
two arrays
again this question is from hard
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition add into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
or we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly we'll copy
this question and see if it is able to
solve this question or not first we have
to create a new chat
I'll be
all the constraints
let's see what charity has to say for
this particular question
let's
ask it to generate a code this time it
has only generated a logic not exactly
Logic the approach indeed they are going
to follow or anyone can follow to solve
this question
let me ask if it can generate a code
okay it's definitely taking longer time
to generate this code
okay here is the code which is possible
python implementation and
[Music]
okay the code is generated and it's
mentioning that the code takes in an
input an array of integer called nums so
basically uh it's explaining that what
it actually is doing which is pretty
much explained in the question itself
that what exactly it needs to function
like and what will be the variables and
what will be the inputs and how it needs
to be segregated to uh obtain our
Optimum result
so
let's copy this
and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know uh
again we could see that
past self parameter
okay
and then
attribute error let's quickly copy it
paste it over here
see what Char GPD has to say about it
okay
that you have seen that after placing
the error it's giving that error message
you're seeing suggests that there's a
problem with the function name in your
code so the error message is indicating
that there is no function called minimum
difference within the solution uh also I
have seen that apart from the function
name it doesn't have a self parameter so
let me just write it down
elf
argument
apps wait let me copy it that will be
better
and write the
new code with it
let me see if it can generate a new code
this time
so yeah it has a great show there is an
example and here's the code
I have copied this
and
paste it over
see any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code
but yeah we can definitely think of
running now
let's run this code
we copy it and paste it over here again
an error has prompted out I
don't know how valid
code will get after projecting this
error over here in charge GPD
so yeah definitely considering the error
message you are seeing is indicated that
the function is returning INF which is
not a valid value for the expected
return type integer
so in the base case where I and J are
both 0 the value of is set to float
which is positively Infinity however the
expected output is an integer so this
valid this value is not valid so again
considering this change the
chargeability is giving a new code so
let us see how valid this new code is
okay I can see that it has changed the
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed but it has uh written a new
syntax a new logic over there
let's see how accurate charge GPT here
is
now okay we have pasted logic
uh yeah as
oh okay sorry I need to remove these two
lines
now let's quickly run this program
okay so now as you can see it could only
pass one test case
but not the first two so there's no
point of submitting this code as you can
see that the logic for the score or this
code and as a whole is not
well moving on
next in the list we have is
longest common subpar now let's see
longest
common
so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27 now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you
cannot just miss out on any
specifications
talking about the constraints called B
and paste
now enter
giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't want any code
over here so let's try
that if it can present a code
because I have asked to write a code for
this and yes charge GPT has definitely
agreed to provide me a code for it uh
charging is done with its explanations
I'll type it out and wait for the new
code which will contain self as a
parameter that it's the score is pretty
similar to the previous one it's just
that it's using the self argument the
function as it was mentioned by me
so let's quickly copy this code
paste it over here
check for the indentation
we run this code
I should be in here
okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charge EBD
has to say about this
okay the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounds checked before being used to
access elements in the path and TP
arrays okay so we have found a new code
let's quickly copy this code and see if
this code is capable of you know
eliminating the errors we
probably found
click copy and paste
let me check correlation
done and run
then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet charging is not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list
that is going to be uh sum of total
strength of wizards hopefully this
question does from married for child GPT
and prove itself lucky the charity graph
for this video because for now we can
see it's a 50 50 scene uh half of the
question chargible was able to provide
Solutions with and have other questions
charging Beauty couldn't actually figure
out what
needs to be done even the logic and
approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct
so let me search for this
question some of total
strength of wizards again a hard
category question so let's have a look
at the question first
let's copy this question
create a new chat
paste it over here
and
look for constraints now that we have
copied it
paste it and enter
he is giving an approach how you can
actually think of a solution for this
particular question charge ability has
not generated any code
uh let me ask for it
okay
so here's an example again they have
implemented the code in Python now it is
also giving a note that the approach is
valid only if you are allowed to modify
the original array and also we are not
working on down over
function and then write this
coat so let's see if we can do it with
self argument
okay so yeah there's an example it's
generating the code
okay so let's see
what's the update with the code
here
yes
let's add
solution
and run the code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why
okay
this error
and paste it over here
we have to say
the error message solution object has no
attribute more suggest that there is a
class name solution and the code is
trying to access an attribute named mod
on an instance of that class with
attribute doesn't exist we probably need
to make more specifications and if it
still doesn't works then it clearly
classifies that charge GPD doesn't takes
every point or a classification uh you
know in consideration which ultimately
uh
you know reflects on the solution
the new code is here let me quickly
paste it
okay
let's try running this code let's see if
this works
try running it again
it has a runtime error was unable to
solve one more question now that we have
tried and tested a huge spectrum of
questions from lead code on charge GPT
we can conclude that though charge GPD
is an amazing tool with the bright
future it's has its own limitations and
maybe it is not ready to replace humans
or compete with human brains these
questions were picked from a list of
frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations chat GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
just shows that a proper solution do
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts charging was not
able to find the correct answer but we
can also give charge GPD the benefit of
doubt that it's still it's in in its
initial phase and still there are a lot
of aspects that need to be worked on so
probably in future charge GPT can take
an upper hand over this but for now
charge GPD needs to do a lot of work for
these situations on that note we present
you Ai and machine learning boot camp
elevate your professional journey by
enrolling in this Ai and ml bootcamp
course acquire expertise in machine
learning deep learning and reinforcement
learning natural language processing
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and Beyond this eiml bootcamp offers
live sessions led by industry
professionals practical Labs projects
aligned with industry needs and master
classes by Celtic instructors hurry up
and enroll Now find the complete course
details from the link in the description
box so we'll start with the first trip
that is change your dashboard appearance
so for that we'll move to chair GPD and
you could change the desktop appearance
for Dash to code appearance of charge
debating you can customize your
dashboard by going to settings and
choosing a new theme or layout so for
settings
you will go here and in general you can
just select the theme that is light you
can change it to dark system theme or
light theme so these are the options you
can use to change your dashboard
appearance so this can help you create a
more comfortable and personalized
working environment for example you can
change the color scheme and you can also
change the font size also and you can
generally change the font size by just
zooming in the window
and the second tip we have is switch on
beta features so we are moved back to
charge repeat and here you can see the
beta features so for that we'll go in
settings and beta that is custom
instructions try a new feature that lets
you share anything you would like charge
gbd to consider closets responses so we
have switched on these beta features the
plugins try a version of chat repeat
that knows when and how to use
third-party plugins that you enable the
code interpreter that is a version of
child Tubidy that knows how to write and
execute python code and can work with
file uploads so asking for help with
data analysis image conversions or
editing a code file and these files not
persist Beyond a single session so these
are the plugins or the beta features
that we have turned on and we are using
them and in chat gbt4 gpt4 you could see
that is code interpreter beta and the
plugins beta they both are available for
us so this was the second tip that is
switch on the beta features and you can
use them that is you can toggle on beta
features to try out new and experimental
features if you like trying out new
features you can switch on beta features
there are experimental features that are
still being tested keep in mind that
they might not always work perfectly and
the next is change the tone of your
writing that is you can ask chat GPT can
you rewrite any sentence in a more
formal way so now we will ask a prompt
to check GPT that is can you rewrite
this in a more formal tone and what we
can ask is that could be hey how are you
okay so we'll ask this so you could see
that the chart GPT has changed the tone
of the sentence or the imperative you
were asking that is hey how are you now
greetings how do you find yourself today
so this is a more formal tone and you
can ask chargpt for more such responses
that is give me more such responses
so you can change the tone of the
sentence that is you could give any
sentence or any imperative or any
language to chat GPT and you can ask for
any tone that could be emotional that
could be funny tone or that could be
sarcastic tone so chat Jeopardy would
reply with the particular tone
so this was our third tip and now moving
on you'll see the fourth tip that is use
chat GPT for quick learning so you can
ask can you explain the basics of
anything that could be the simple
biology Concepts the solar system and
you can use charge apt for quick
learning that is for instance you could
ask any prompt
that is here we will ask chair GPT that
teach me
how to write
hello world in Python
so you can see that Jupiter responded
that is showed writing a hello world
program in Python is quite
straightforward due to python Simplicity
and here's how you can do it that is
print hello world and in this code it
has given you some sentences so you can
just read them and understand how the
code works that is print is a built-in
python function that outputs specified
information to the screen then the text
that is hello world that is an inverted
commas is a string which is a type of
data representing text then the
parenthesis that are used to include the
arguments of the function so when you
run this program it will give the output
of the text that is hello world to the
console so this was the fourth tip and
moving on now we have our fifth tip that
is view the plugin store so now chat GPT
has many plugins that is we will create
a new chat and in gbt4 you could just
click on plugins So currently no plugins
are enabled and this is the plugin store
so the developers are developing plugins
so you could use them and be more
productive and add more features to the
chat repeating so you could see that is
aipdf that is super fast interactive
chats with PDFs of any site complete
with page references for fact checking
ask your PDF chat with PDF Expedia
notable link reader so these are the
plugins that you could use
and this comes with the gpt4 version
that is the paid version
so you could enable any plugin and you
can write any prompt and the chat GPT
will respond to it now moving on to the
next step
that is tip 6 use the web browsing
feature so with gpt4 and with the beta
versions you get a feature to search
with Bing or to browse with bank that is
not available for my account or from my
area so this is the new tip you can use
it if you have the paid version and if
you are accessible for the beta version
of browsing with pink so this was our
next tip and moving on we will see our
seventh tip that is template eyes useful
prompts so you can ask can you create a
10 minute full body workout using some
kind of dumbbells or a barbell roll and
save this prompt for future use you can
also templateize useful prompts for
instance you can also ask can you create
a menu or to-do list and save this
prompt for future use so we'll see a
quick example that would be
creator
10 minute
full body workout and that would be
using so you could see that the charge
GPT has given us a templatized routine
so as a quick high intensity power
workout that you can complete in about
10 minutes that is bubble deadlifts and
bubble squats bubble overhead press
bubble rules verbal bench press so for
that you also need to have bench press
also and the notice remember the key to
this workout is intensity and form not
necessarily the paid used okay so this
is how you can templatize useful prompts
and moving on the next step we have is
summarize text that is you can paste a
long article and ask chat Jeopardy to
convert it or summarize in few sentences
for example you can paste a long arcade
article so I'll show you how we can do
that we will just search for
simply known articles
so
use any article we'll just copy it and
give this to chat GPD that is paste it
and ask it can you
summarize this article
five sentences
so you know that this prompt will just
summarize the whole article into five
sentences and this is the feature of
charge GPT to summarize anything and in
a very concise manner and this was a tab
eighth and moving on
the next tip we have is analyze your
writing pattern
that is can you you can ask charity can
you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it that
is you can give it any text or chat that
you have done you can just copy that
chat and give that as a prompt to chat
GPT and you can then write a prompt that
can you analyze my writing style and
generate a paragraph by making it on any
topic so the chat objective will analyze
your writing pattern and when will mimic
your style and you can also ask it to
act as a famous person like you can
to act like Elon Musk and give your
thoughts on AI
so here
we will ask strategy that is
act as Elon Musk and give your thoughts
on air
so you could see that it has stated that
artificial intelligence was immense
potential for human advancement it's
eventually digital superintelligent and
can go beyond human intelligence but it
is not saying that it can perfectly act
as Elon Musk or it can directly speak to
Elon Musk but you can provide a
perspective based on his public
statements on the topic of artificial
intelligence so the child CPT has
analyzed all its statements that are
present that is gpt4 has some browsing
features so it has analyzed all the
statements and on behalf of that it has
given us the result and now moving on to
the next step practice act as an
examiner so you can ask can you check
this essay for grammatical errors you
can ask it to check your project or even
grade your homework so as we have copy
pasted the article you can copy paste
your if you want to check your code or
debug your code you can just give it to
chat jpt and it will give you the
suggestions or it will point out some
matters and can give you a perfect code
or you can just ask him to get some
grammatical errors in your article or
essay so this was the 10th tip that is
act as an examiner and now the next is
formatted outputs so you can give any
data to chat jpt and ask him to format
this into tables and you can ask him to
add some columns to the tables that
would be Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
you can ask him to prepare a to-do list
or something like that so you can format
your outputs chargpt will respond to
that
so for that we'll just give it a prompt
to charge APD that is format the days of
week in a table and days put days in
column so let's see so you could see
that it has given us and it has given
all the days in one column so you have
to correct your prompts and rewrite your
prompts and see what chat Jeopardy is
responding with those problems so you
have to be concise and be conscious and
just regenerative problems so now moving
on to and next step
that is tip number 12 let us generate to
do list you can say I need to do grocery
shopping finish a report and call my
friend today and can you create a to-do
list for me so chat GPT can create to-do
list just tell it what task you need to
complete and it will create a to-do list
for you you can just you just have to
give it a prompt and the next step we
have is explain it to a child so this is
you can ask can you explain how a rocket
Works to a five-year-old you can ask
chat Jeopardy to explain complex
Concepts in simple terms just say
explain it to a child followed by the
concept so for example you can also ask
that can you explain quantum physics to
a child so we will just try this prompt
that is explain
quantum physics
to a child
so this will give you
so you could see that the charge GPT has
given the answer that is absolutely
there's a very simple way to explain
quantum physics to a child and it has
given a Lego books example you can build
a castle a spaceship or a whole city so
this is how you can use this prompt
that was the tip number 13 that is
explaining to a child then the next step
we have is Shadow chat thread links so
after having a productive conversation
with chargeability you can share this
conversation by clicking on the share
button and sending generated link to
your colleagues this is a great way to
collaborate with others for instance if
you are working on a project with a team
you can share the link to a chat thread
so everyone can see the conversation and
contribute so I will show you how you
can do it that is this is the share
button share a chat and you can just
copy the link and send it to anyone and
you can collaborate with them and now
moving on to a next tip that is tip
number 15 that is export data to mail if
you want to export a chat you can click
on the export button and enter your
email address you will receive a copy of
the chat in your inbox this useful
feature is used if you want to save a
record of your conversation or if you
need to share the information with
someone who doesn't have access to
charitivity so I will show you how you
can do it so simply you have to go here
click on settings and go to data
controls and here is your option that is
export data so just click on export
confirm export and the successfully
exported data you should receive an
email shortly with your data and now
moving on we will see another tip that
is
organize your chat history
so you can organize your chat history
that is you can edit it and you can name
anything that is
tips for share jpd
so this is how you can organize your
chat history
and now moving on
now we'll see the next step that is go
minimalist
so what do you understand where
minimalist is you can just
close this sidebar so this is the
minimalist options here you can just use
the chat GPT here so in settings you can
choose a minimalist theme which will
remove any unnecessary elements from
your dashboard leaving only with
Essentials and if you prefer cleaner
look you can go minimalist and this
removes any unnecessary elements and you
can delete all your history that is in
settings you can find the delete all
history button clicking this will erase
all your previous chats and for privacy
reasons you might want to delete your
chat history you can do this by going to
a settings and selecting delete old
history so this was a tip number 18 that
is delete all your history
so we'll just go to settings data
controls and here we have chat history
and training that is turned on if you
will turn off it will just turn off and
it will also act as an incognito mode
and here you can clear all the chats
this will delete all the history
and the next step we have is describe
images and the Nexus summarize YouTube
videos
so this is available with the beta
features of Bing that is you can just
write
describe image
and paste any image link here so the
child GPT will describe the image for
you and if you want to like know about
any YouTube video so you can just write
describe YouTube video and then paste
the link and it will describe the
YouTube video for you and that is
available with the beta feature of
browsing with Bing and if that is
available with you and currently that is
not available with me you can like if
you if the feature is available with you
that is a beta feature you would able to
see here that was the beta feature and
you can also go into settings and beta
and check out if the feature is
available for you or not
if you are looking for ways to generate
passive income without putting in too
much effort thanks to the advancement in
artificial intelligence and chat boards
it's now possible to earn money using
these Technologies in this video we'll
explore some of the effective ways to
generate passive income with church
ability charity is known for being the
world's smartest generative Ai and is
changing the game when it comes to
making money online with this
revolutionary free tool you can earn
with little skill and no Capital
required there is an exciting New Era of
artificial intelligence and now is the
perfect time to get involved and take
advantage of this opportunity people are
using shared GPT for YouTube blogging
freelancing and for many other ways to
make money so let's dive in and discover
how to make money using share Jeopardy
and generate various passive incomes
there are variety of ways that you can
make money using charitability we'll
discuss few of them in this video and
we'll start with first we'll see the
list of all the ideas from which you can
make money the first is get business
ideas from second is freelancing third
is build a software fourth is boost your
affiliate marketing with chat Jeopardy's
email expertise with this leverage chat
Jeopardy for blogging success the next
is unlock the potential of charge Deputy
for affiliate marketing and then we have
utilized chat jbd for ebook writing and
self-publishing this is the main thing
what people are doing to make money
using chair Tubidy and then we have
utilized chat everybody to enhance your
YouTube channel and then we have writing
lyrics for music so starting them one by
one we'll start with get business ideas
from chat Jeopardy by getting to know
your interest talent and obstacles chat
jpd can generate tailored business
Concepts that align with your
expectations let's Dive Right In and ask
Chad Jeopardy for some business ideas
for computer science engineer who has
experience in digital marketing and
sales are chat repeating and ask him
that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars to generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
and this is
a day with minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
okay uh you know it took 10 hours
to this side Hustle
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expensive sales and
marketing the several side levels two
generate thousand dollars income per day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat GPT and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea or digital
products you can write that and he will
guide you how you can start it or you
could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the site
with this
and then you press enter and you can see
that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side hustle
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfing Venture identify
your expertise
at manure areas of knowledge skills and
passion and then he has stated two Zone
product format create valuable content
set up an online platform Market your
products build an audience optimize for
conversions provide excellent customer
support so these are the parts he has
stated and moreover you can elaborate
those parts also you can just ask chat
Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chat upd and moving on the
next would be freelancing so take your
freelancing game to the next level with
chair Jeopardy this date of the art AI
tool is enabling professionals to earn
extra income and produce top quality
content that Bose clients companies are
even offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chat GPT
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with chat
jpt you can craft compelling headlines
and calls to action with chat GPT and
moreover you can do create social media
content for posts or marketing for other
people or any advertising agency you can
write captivating short stories using
chat Jeopardy and you can conduct
hashtag research using chatributing that
is you can find what is trending and
offer your services to other people and
gain money so these are the ways in
which you could freelance and have some
money in your pockets you could just
write a command that would be write a
blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post on
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the
what your client required you can use
for that and write the perfect without
plagiarism content that would be blog
post and you can translate any language
with chai triputi you can write
comparative headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economy
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've won this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat GPD
so now it will write the blog post that
will be in 800 words
so
that's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of
five Learners what he has to say about
our courses we need to keep updating
your skills on a regular basis no matter
what level you're at I recently
completed the professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning now coming back so the third
passive income you could make using
charge of ideas building a software
imagine this scenario you have an issue
with your online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using report provided by the AI
and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a reading Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a NAC
of four coding why not use charge
ability to create software tools that
can make a real happy start by
identifying common pain points that also
you can ask from charity you can just
ask the chat jpt I want to create a
software to help others during or in
online processes in online e-commerce so
he'll give you suggestions and then you
can proceed with those suggestions and
create a software and then you can sell
it or you can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat jpt tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that chat Deputy processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charitivity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
email marketer
and you need to
sell my CRM software
so right
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart your email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are generally interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as I email marketed
person okay this is for me and you could
start from here at your company we have
developed a powerful CRM solution
tailored specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features username okay
here is written for uh email marketers
only as targeted audience that is email
marketer no issue you can ask him to
change that and like you can craft
compelling emails with chair Jeopardy
and this is where chat triple truly
shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about by
your site imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair Jeopardy offers an array
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome writer's block
chat Jeopardy assist bloggers by
generating ideas crafting outlines
anyone providing complete routes for
blog posts say goodbye to our spend on
research the charge Deputy you can
access relevant information statistics
and facts and mere seconds elevate your
blogging game and Unleash Your Potential
with this an invaluable source
and then you can add it and proof rate
using charge update if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on U.S economic that we have seen
in freelancing uh side Hustle but here
you can write and not only write but
also if you have added some points with
your research you can proofread and edit
by using charge APD that is for bloggers
chat Jeopardy proves to be a valuable
asset by offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog post shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structuring your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat GPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
4 and the topic could be online shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you could mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it provides conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging charge up it is capabilities
you can post on meaningful interactions
cultivated lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge GPT
Brokers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate the target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog journey to relieve a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side hustle that is unlock
the potential of shared Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this vlogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and chat
Jeopardy can be your trusted Ally on
this rewarding Journey users of charge
Deputy can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless value for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
your strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with while collaborating
with chair Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with video audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you draft
engaging articles record compiling audio
content or script captivating videos
that highlight the benefits and value of
the products or services that you are
promoting so remember affiliate
marketing is a process that requires
dedication and perseverance through
consistent effort and the support of
Charity you can unlock the potential of
earning substantial income by promoting
products and services that resonate with
your audience and this was for the
affiliate marketing and the next big
thing is utilize chair Jeopardy for
ebook writing and self-publishing so are
you a passionate writer seeking fresh
and innovative ideas look no further
revolutionizes your writing experience
in a recent report that revealed that AI
written ebooks have experienced a
remarkable search on Amazon so you could
just go and charge deputy and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and H
should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of chapters
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapter that is introducing setting
the stage for personal growth
discovering your authentic self
cultivating a positive mindset and after
that you can ask chat Deputy to
elaborate these topics that would be in
some words in some pages and you can use
the same content to write a book and you
can also ask the title from the chat jpd
so with jbd as you create a companion
the possibilities are boundless you
don't need to possess the skills of
literary genius to make an impact in the
e-book Market Kindle Direct publishing
offers seamless platform to Showcase
your book and make it easily accessible
to enthusiastic readers by leveraging
charge Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income using chair
GPD moving on we have next passive
income that is utilized chat Jeopardy to
enhance your YouTube channel
so chargeable is an invaluable tool that
can assist you in generating captivating
video ideas you can ask him the video
ideas also and this is the creative
block which activity can even cool the
extra mile by creating a script for
YouTube videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask share jpt
I want to create a YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing the script for that
so you could see that chair jpd has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of gbt GDP what exactly is GDP and
why is it such an important measure of
our country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with chair Deputy today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on
the next we have is writing lyrics for
music so when it comes to music the
words we use in songs are super
important they have the power to make us
feel all kinds of emotions and connect
with people and now there's a cool tool
called chargeability that can help you
write awesome song lyrics with Chad
Jeopardy you can take your ideas and
turn them into beautiful words that
touch people's heart it's like having a
virtual writing buddy that help you come
up with catchy lines and cool Rhymes you
can play around with different ways to
express yourself and make your lyrics
stand out so you can chat Jeopardy to
write lyrics for you on that note we
present you Ai and machine learning boot
camp elevate your professional journey
by enrolling in this Ai and ml bootcamp
course acquire expertise in machine
learning deep learning and reinforcement
learning natural language processing
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and Beyond this AIML bootcamp offers
live sessions led by industry
professionals practical Labs project 6
aligned with industry needs and master
classes by Caltech instructors hurry up
and enroll Now find the complete course
details from the link in the description
box chat deputy and googlebot are the
two ah chatbots you must have heard
about they bought an immense change in
the way we operate now from web
development to digital marketing from
cloud computing to cyber security they
are now everywhere you just name it and
they have it trust me the use of these
chatbots has changed everything now if
you want to create a complete YouTube
video just ask them and rest assured
they'll take care for your task not just
that but if you want to create a search
engine optimized content whether it be
for your website or on YouTube these AI
tools can help you with such content
search engine optimization is not easy
it takes a lot to optimize your content
so that people can get to see it on top
what are these AI tools threat to people
engaged in search engine optimization in
this video we'll not discuss what these
AI tools can do for you but we'll
discuss if AI tools like chat GPT or
googlebot will take over SEO or not but
before that if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily hit
the Bell icon to get notified whenever
we drop a new video the goal of SEO is
to make a website more visible and bring
in income from natural traffic it
entails crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with Purdue will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SC ranking
hootsu Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details hear it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I moved to the United States four years
ago to live with my family I have a
background in social media by doing the
same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing for Purdue University
offered by simple learner
I like that it could provide such as
flexible schedule for attending the live
classes it came with a recorded feature
with a blessing for working
professionals like me tell me make
significant progress I am already using
these kids to sell my products online I
believe that I have come one step closer
to living my dream life in America so
let's talk about SEO developments with
chat GPT and Google bar and notably the
influence AI is anticipated to have on
search engines have been highlighted by
the recent launches of Google's bar and
chat Deputy assistant bin although these
recent advancements pose a severe engine
they also present opportunities for
digital marketers to seize in the world
full of SEO things change all the time
and Subs are never stable the page that
a search engine displays as a result of
a user's search query is known as the
search engine result pitch or server
this is why it's important to be able to
change with the times and benefit from
new technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for
keyword research heading ideas and
content optimizations this is so they
can concentrate on the jobs that need
human interaction small sites May
produce original SEO friendly material
much more quickly with chargity then
they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
way various weeks the Google AdWords
Keyword Planner and the Google Trends
tool are two of the most widely used
free artificial intelligence keyword
research tools you may find keywords
with a lot of search volume and little
competition using these tools another
crucial aspect to take into account when
choosing keywords for your website is
intent this is so because users
frequently have a purpose while
searching for goods and services
although it might be challenging to
ensure your website appears high on
search engine result Pages especially
with Google's algorithm adjustments SEO
companies and marketers must constantly
check their websites to make sure that
their websites are not falling in the
servers they can use AI to automatically
analyze search traffic statistics and
website content to spot potential issues
before they arise they can then address
these problems and offer consistent
organic rankings this is a game changer
for SEO companies and marketers who
realize on manual SEO efforts to get
traffic to their websites but the main
question is will chat GPT or googlebot
take over SE the answer is clearly a big
why chat Bots like chat deputy and Bart
cannot replace SEO they can help
generate content for your website or
video but SEO involves more than just
content creation it includes tasks
keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search search engines like
Google and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build required expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lies not in
their mechanical abilities but in their
creativity and ability to understand
what people are searching for and why
that's something that AI Technologies
may never be able to replicate and it's
what makes human SEO experts such a
valuable asset so while it's true that
AI Technologies may eventually be able
to take over some of the aspects of SEO
there's still plenty of rooms for human
experts to thrive whether you are a
seasoned SEO professional or just
starting out here's still a place for
you in this exciting and ever evolving
field
let's keep an eye on the developments in
AI technology and see how it can augment
and enhance our skills rather than
replacing them entirely who knows with
the power of AI and human expertise
combined the future of SEO may be even
brighter than we can imagine so with
that we have come to the end of this
discussion although everyone can have
different opinions on this but I hope
you guys must have got an idea
why these AI tools are not a threat to
SC if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will help you address this so here we
wrap up chat GPT tutorial for beginners
if you have any questions feel free to
post them in the comment section share
the video with your friends and do not
forget to like share and subscribe to
Simply learn to never miss any updates
from us thanks for watching staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign